I am an ASM artist I'm an ASM artist I'm
an ASM artist I am an ASM artist I'm an
asmrs I am a Asm artist I am an ASM
artist
[Music]
s
sorry
[Music]
I need Trace
Chase I
I my channel focuses on
nostalgic childhood
when the girl in back of class
ASMR
ASMR today we're going to do a guided
meditation so author start out by taking
a deep breath
and now
exhale
great job I want you to think
and imagine your favorite person
world
sometimes
we wish we could say some things
but there are always words left unsaid
[Music]
foreign
here for a drink okay
so how's your day been your boyfriend
broke up with you
may I ask why what happened
okay you found him cheating with your
best friend in bed
foreign
I like to have a sense of humor when I'm
doing ASMR
awn
my channel now
for about two years
so I do a lot of real person hair play
back scratching
okay so you're sitting on your
boyfriend's stained futon and then a cat
scratched your eyes
you lost your sight are you liking kind
of seat belt
Ice Cube still
do something very
cold weather
but I guess more on social
media and I am
there's a lot of
a lot of entertaining
it's called
foreign
out of everybody else's
I'll say well maybe that would just felt
like a dead giveaway I voted
killing my
I could feel
good feel tight now
ASMR
something for you yeah do you do you
only do
only I do guided meditation
I also do
whole place
um I don't I literally just put the
screen over with some artwork so
my forte is my
is my um
yeah so
I do I show my face for for the guided
anime stuff he was kind of like
why don't you dress
up
honestly
it's a new phone
of her like
two cosplay and
and it's definitely
definitely Inspirations but
for now I just want viewers to really
really the essence of my voice
and easily replicate
I felt like his guided meditation was a
bit entry level
foreign
[Music]
are you talking about are you talking to
me
yeah airbrush not the caterpillar
eyebrows oh no
oh
it's fine I'll take offense to it I just
think it's like
inside about what they like for
like one like what do you do
is back scratching and airbrushing and
face tracing like nostalgic childhood
triggers
foxcrotch AirPlay mostly and then like I
do some other kind of triggers
and Julie
a streamer
so it's just more like a role play dirty
talk and
that time
are you on YouTube you do as well I do
I do an open
Panic poker are you
foreign
do you think that the mole is still in
the box and you wish to continue playing
the game please raise your hand
if the lights turn green that means you
voted them all out and you win the
lights turn red and as the mole is still
in the box
[Music]
foreign
please remove your blindfolds one two
three
please raise their hand one two three
you guys are nodding what gave it away I
you do have a really good voice
thank you so much
acting
so
this is a really really good challenge
for me to
be on camera
pressure it is really cool though
like when you talk
but it's nice
yeah it's time to open
it
[Music]
[Applause]